all right berlin and angel blue
yes
berlin and angel you guys how would you
describe your
relationship i gotta title this video
something what would you title this
you are a master slave master it's a
master slave relationship yes
so berlin is the is your master yes
and in what ways are you his slave
in every way whatever he
requests i do
to what i mean only in a sexual
context
actually it's in every way whether it's
sexual um house
or um
outside of the house
anything
anything
i'll do it
we have a consensual
power exchange
relationship
she has given me
the authority to exercise
[Music]
her decision making
and
i have taken the responsibility
of
exercising that decision making
in a way that um
hopefully will help to fulfill
her potential as i see it
and
how old are you angel 45 45 in berlin
you are
72 72 and you guys have been together
for how long
oh
we always say 30 000 years
but it's been um
it's been years
even years okay and so berlin you are a
successful
professional yes i am well we'll not get
into the details of that but
uh you have you have
a well-paying job and you're successful
angel you describe your
life up until you've met berlin
a bit just in a short yes uh up until i
met him i was
unruly
i was a little wild i was
running a mock
and getting in trouble
and i didn't really have focus i didn't
have direction and
i was
it wasn't a good life
it wasn't a good life to
to live not that way and after i met him
everything got so much better your life
has improved since you've been with
berlin oh drastically and berlin do you
you've had
relationships marriages before this yes
i have
i have and i i'm guessing because i've
done some other interviews with people
in similar lifestyles
were your pre some of your previous
relationships were more vanilla as they
call it yes and quite frankly um
i think that was
to a great extent a problem and
i don't think i was honest enough with
myself
in the past
to know to to
to um
consciously be aware of
what i wanted
and to seek it
and to get it
and you're married now
yes
and you describe your relationship as
happy you're fulfilled very happy
very happy we
i know it sounds strange but we do lead
a normal life we do literally three
times a week
so it
it's just like anybody else except
i'm the slave i do what my master tells
me that's the only difference
and i'm sure some of the
viewers that watch this will say this is
demented it's it's sick it's
perverted it's whatever yes people say
that but
i like it and i feel if it's consensual
i mean my life is so much better than
it's ever been
he's very nurturing it's not just
mass you know i'm a tyrant that's gonna
bully you no
it's uh there's nurturing and so much
guidance
he gives me so much direction stability
um
i feel like i have a schedule now you
know he keeps me on a schedule
i have to check in i do check in a lot
if we're not together the times we're
not together he texts me
i have to text every hour on the hour
when i'm doing where i'm at who i'm with
he asked me are you drinking the water
are you um just
i try to provide guidance
and structure yes and discipline
and when i say discipline
um i know what comes to mind is often
something like corporal punishment or
something like that
i'm speaking of discipline uh
even in a much greater way um i could
have never
gotten to where i am without the
discipline
to do things i don't want to do
because
it will get me where i want to be
since we met um
angel blue has uh
graduated gotten one degree and she's
in university pursuing another degree
um she could have never she never she
could have but she wouldn't have done it
because she lacked the structure
and the discipline
to fulfill the uh
the requirements for graduation and you
enjoy being in this dominant role oh i i
yes you probably demand it yes
were you dominant in your other
relationships as well no
and i think that was a mistake
i don't think that i
allowed myself
to
[Music]
it was too taboo it was to
you know i was always taught that was
bad
and
it isn't
it works
and it um
it's good for both of us yeah
of course thank you
um i just wanted to add
that i've helped him
yes uh with
opening like i
i've told him
it's okay
do you could do this and you could do
that and
uh when we first met i emailed him a
whole list of things that he could do
that some people might consider severe
or a little out there
and he he told me thank you so much
because
i
didn't know if that was um going to be
disrespectful to women
and i didn't know if you were going to
get upset and i told him no i'm
please do it please so
that's helped him open up
to
to where he's at now
and i greatly enjoy the role
of not the role well it's a role but
um
it's also a purpose and uh
of
of providing and protecting
and taking care of
providing leadership for our whole
family
it
it works
it just works
are you in the similar dominant
uh
role at work
um
at work we have um
uh
no we have a different different power
dynamic at work
at work it's more democratic and more
who happens to arise to the occasion at
the particular time and it's more of a
con
consensus operation but
your
personality
is
you know this fits your personality yes
being a dominant partner yes and and
angel blew your
submissive role fits your personality
no
well sometimes but other times
before i met him i was very
getting in trouble um i got kicked out
of high school for um
um for
getting aggressive with the school
counselor
and uh
so you you tend to
become out of control yes very so so
berlin's influence
tames you yes and that helps me so much
because
you know i
had problems getting arrested and all
kinds of things and
yeah i would have a short fuse at times
so um he's helped me with that
how did you first discover that you guys
had this dynamic in your relationship
well it's interesting because when we
first met we didn't know that we were
i didn't know he was into this and he
didn't know i was into this at all and
um
we went out a few times and then
we realized it and after he realized it
we started to get really into it more
and more and that's how it happened you
ever talk about it and say you know this
is this is what we're both really into
yes we made a contract
and he colored me and he um i signed the
contract
and it as i did yes we both signed it
and it's a lifetime
and beyond
because we both have responsibilities
we both have um
we both have responsibilities
yes hers is centered around um
service
and mine is centered around um
guidance
and um
and care
and so uh
hers is centered around service and
obedience and mine is centered around
leadership
and uh guidance
and um
direction
and
is it okay if i add something
i was just yes
use your discretion
that there is no getting out of this
because you can't get a divorce in three
years if you're no we can't even leave
this earth without getting out of this
our contract is
when i mentioned the 30 000 years that
we've known each other it's going to
keep going there's no
there's no getting out of this contract
and we've been through everything that
that any other couple
would have ran away from
everything and anything you can think of
and we have we still say have there been
moments where you you want out of this
relationship because it's just too
whatever
well of course there's been moments
where we both
felt like
oh you know
but it didn't matter
it didn't matter because
we're we're bound let me ask you a
personal question is is the sex
uh better for lack of a better word um
because of this dynamic yes
it's one thousand percent better it's
i wouldn't
if god forbid he passed away or anything
happened
i would not want to go
back to a vanilla relationship i would
seek something like this out
because the sex is
to me it's very intense
and it's very sacred
there's something very sacred about it
and that that can power our relationship
through all kinds of yes rough seas
right yes
through anything i feel do anything yes
through anything
there's a teacher
there's a great expression of giving
and receiving
in
our sexual dynamics is love the basis of
your relationship you would say
is there a lot of love in this
relationship
i would i i don't know about you but i
would say yes he's very nurturing
he's extremely nurturing
i would say yes yeah
because a lot of people are going to say
this this is
this is a messed up relationship
you know i'm sure you i'm sure people do
they do say that and to both of us to
both of us uh people have to when you go
out to the grocery store or to a party
for example are you wearing the collar
oh it's been worse uh we've been to
morocco and uh i was tied to a rope that
he was holding
uh in mexico i was uh chained
on i guess it was like a leash
and then in paris um
we got a little
kinky
yes and this guy
he
he was i think muslim he got really
upset and angry
not at him at me he started cussing me
out and i don't know what language it
was i didn't understand but
i think he was telling me i was going to
burn in hell or something like that
so yeah we get flack but
i'm i don't really care and your kids
yes yes together
yes
and uh
you know i also want to make something
no injuries
so it's like
you know she doesn't walk away with a
broken arm
or
you know internal injuries that cause
some kind of difficulty or
anything of that nature right
and it's not because she has a limit
it's because i exercise
that's part of my responsibility
that's what i'm doing my response
can you give me some examples of the
extent that this
um
slave relationship
manifests itself i mean what what kind
of things do you
uh
well if i spent the day with you what
would i see if you spent the day with us
oh well that depends what day it is
it depends because um
there's certain days when we're high
protocol and there's certain days when
we're low protocol and there's certain
days when we're no protocol oh really
yes so on a no protocol day
you could just chill at home watch a
movie eat popcorn like like a normal
yeah vanilla relationship exactly and
then on the high protocol days
i want to notice that you started to say
normal relationship and you withdrew
that
so i appreciate that
because
normal in the sense of perhaps
more often encountered
but um not necessarily better or
healthier exactly
i mean
uh there's a great i think there's a lot
of unh unhappy relationships out there
there's a great deal of affection
between us
and there's a great bond
irrespective of affection besides
um
it's kind of interesting um
[Music]
it's not just
affection that keeps us together
it's also
because
that's
what we have consensually undertaken
and um
chosen not to abandon period
and conforming is something that just
doesn't
interest you it doesn't interest me at
all
most people are looking to conform and
do it do what we're supposed to do in
society and that
can [ __ ]
relationships and all kinds of things i
it just uh i suspect there's
so much
there's a lot of giving there's a lot of
receiving
on both ends um
you know she may be my slave but at the
same time
i have to always
be aware and conscious
what she needs
whether she expresses it verbally or
doesn't express it verbally i just have
to be aware
it's a full-time job it is a full-time
job yes it's a full-time and because
you're older
and successful berlin this might look
like a sugar baby sugar daddy
relationship but yeah
i suspect it's much much more than that
oh it's so much deep i wouldn't even say
it is that i'm just if it if it includes
those kind of
elements then
there's it seems like i can sense that
there's much more to it than that well
in fact
one of her areas of competence
greater competence than mine
is uh
day-to-day financial affairs so she's in
charge of it i've delegated that to her
that's great he overshadows i overspend
and i'm
a saver
i always like to save i don't like to
use okay so
that takes the sugar baby sugar
oh he there's times when he buys me
things and i'm like
no
no you know like i don't need things i
don't
i don't care for the material
but we are different that way because
he's
he's more um
he's not a materialistic person but he's
more used to the material world and i'm
i come from the opposite
we're complete opposites in every single
way i mean not in our sex life but in in
those ways we're complete i
you know i take the bus still
i take the subway
when when we don't
drive together i don't know how to drive
you know and i'm in la all my life so
that's all i know how to do is take this
away bus
and walk everywhere so
she's really cheap
i'd like to see frugal i like that too i
appreciate that so when it comes to
sugar daddy sugar baby
thing um it doesn't really apply here it
it doesn't really apply it doesn't
really apply no but it would look like
that perhaps oh
i'm sure it does yeah i'm sure it does
so tell me about your your childhoods
your background uh angel blue you grew
up with what kind of family i grew up um
here in l.a
and um
i had a father who
was an alcoholic
and he was very abusive he was very
violent
towards my mother
and my brother and i
you know we
we were living in that
kind of a household that was very
unhealthy
and it's very scary it's very
unpredictable
my father was a type person that would
put a gun to people's heads
he
uh stabbed my mother tried to kill her
the police would
come all the time to our apartment
and then um
we would leave we would hide we would go
to shelters
we would go to orange county
virginia
we had family in virginia and um
he would stalk us he would look for us
so it was
very unpleasant and then when i was
eight he passed away
and then there was
some relief
from that but i was still a very
extremely shy child
so shy i wouldn't there was i think
second grade i wouldn't even talk like
people the other kids thought i was a
mute so it was that bad if i had to pee
sometimes i didn't want to raise my hand
so i would
pee in my feet it was that bad
but things did get better after he
passed away
and berlin tell me how you grew up
well i
i was much more fortunate
i grew up in a
professional household hole
my father was a professional
he was an old-time
husband and father shall we say
at times
one might have considered him to be
physically abusive
but
in retrospect
um
let me just say he was an old-fashioned
dad
and he provided an awful lot
to myself and the whole family
and um
i'm very grateful to both of my parents
um
my mother was extremely loving
and just a wonderful wonderful woman
wonderful person
and my father
served in his professional capacity
served
many people made many people's lives
better
and he provided a great deal
to
his family
and his community
and
i'm grateful very grateful to have had
both of my parents
it's nice to hear
so do you feel like your childhoods may
have
led to
where you guys are in this relationship
today created the dynamic i always feel
that that's true because
um because i grew up watching my father
um
be violent towards my mother and
my master grew up in the same way
his father was violent towards his
mother
so
i think that
witnessing that as a child
not for everybody but for some people it
can do something to you
and you grow up and you're kind of never
the same again and it leads you towards
certain directions and towards certain
things where you can be
kind of relating to your mom's role
and maybe berlin is relating to his
father's role and and
yes clearly to some extent you know
in retrospect i see my father
my father had his worst times
when i was the only child
i witnessed it no one else did
um
and i understand it
um i understand it both in terms of his
history
and in terms of what was going on at the
time
of course i didn't understand any of it
at the time
um but
yes my father was
a tremendous provider
he took care of
the whole family no matter what
um
[Music]
he wouldn't even
let the family know
when there were problems he just
took care of it
would you guys say this is the happiest
point in your lives
i would
i would say um
yes
i feel that i've never had a
relationship in my life that was
this stable
it's brought a lot of stability and it's
gonna sound strange but i actually feel
like this is my most normal
relationship
because um he's helped me step up to the
plate and
do many things that i never thought i
could do
and he's very supportive in every single
way and
i feel extremely blessed
i
thank god every day
that i have found
i have found my master
it sounds like you guys have maybe tried
and failed in some past relationships
and now you've found
a relationship that fits both of your
personalities very well
regardless of what society
thinks of it yes definitely and i think
that
well my master gets a lot of flack
because
i'm his fifth wife
so people can see that as
oh you know
you suck at marriages but i see it as
no it just takes time to find the right
one and i feel that
it took all this time for us
to
to me but you know god saved the best
for last
and i say since two were before i
graduate finish
university they don't count
[Laughter]
you're young
very young obviously wanted a family
very badly
but um
uh
i imagine it would be very difficult to
find a partner that
uh
you can do this with right well
particularly if you don't know that's
what you want right yeah right most
people if you aren't if you aren't even
looking because
it's too taboo to even admit to yourself
then you clearly aren't going to find
what you aren't even aware of
do you suspect there were
that a lot of
relationships could benefit from
better communication a little more
openness about this kind of stuff
better communication certainly
i and i'm not advocating this for anyone
else i'm just
sharing the experience that we have
in the hopes that one maybe it will help
someone else and two
because i think there's
just this
what i'll call inappropriate stigma
attached
it's just
ridiculous
americans probably even humans are very
uptight about sex
yes they are very in relationships and
they they have to look a certain way
and if they don't look the way they're
supposed to look then
everyone
criticizes i think right yes but you
guys aren't hurting anyone no no
berlin's not hurting
angel blue right no no
you you enjoy how he treats you
yes and i like um i do like
i don't know how to wear this but i do
like some violence
you know in the bedroom so
personally i wouldn't be in a
relationship that didn't have that
component to it
and again that's by choice yes that's
all by choice you you prefer that yes
yeah and that's one of the things that i
think got me hooked in when we first met
was that um i had asked people
previously
to do certain things
to me and
they wouldn't because they said oh
that's disrespectful to women blah blah
blah i can't do it
and he always did and he always went
like even
further than you know and i thought wow
okay this is a keeper this is a keeper
right here
and that makes the
the sexual
part of the relationship
more fulfilling
extremely fulfilling
and it does to me too because
there's a clear demonstration
of
well there's a clear demonstration of
service and
obedience there's a clear demonstration
of affection there's a clear giving
a clear
giving
um
we speak in a language that we
understand
physically yes because in our um
master slave relationship there are no
limits so
i can't say no to whatever he requests
and
so far i feel like there has been
nothing that he's requested that would
even
make me
not want to
do it
so we're really in tune i think we're
really yeah you're very in tune yes
that's a great word yeah
and that describe it
and because there are no limits that
means
i have to exercise
my authority responsibly
it's not like i'm some kind of a little
tyrant who says you know like
or who
who will exercise that
authority in an injurious
manner
[Music]
i could
but i won't
it's something that's probably very
important here
which maybe everyone can relate to is i
suspect i'm an outsider here i don't
know anything about this lifestyle but
i'm learning as i do these interviews
that because the communication is so
good with you guys
that that the trust and the
closeness that's developed
and the uniqueness of your relationship
makes it very unlikely that either of
you will stray
100 percent
i've never had better communication
and also you have to have where is he
going to go to find what you offer right
and where am i going to go exactly
you're like yeah
i'm like no i always tell him to you
know when we've had our ups and downs
i've told them ah and every time
there's been that little thing i feel
like
where am i gonna go to i i don't
i feel like nobody else can provide what
he does
i really feel like nobody else
and we spend a lot of time and effort
uh
in that communication
to really know each other
as well as we know each other
and
we do have great communication i'll say
that
yes and trust and trust tremendous
stress
that's great
so interesting
berlin angel blue thank you so much for
telling us about your unique
relationship thank you
have a great time this weekend you're
taking a trip over to mexico yes right
after we leave here we're going straight
to mexico
thank you and thank you for um
thank you for the tenor of the interview
oh sure no i have a very open mind
appreciate it thank you very much
you